สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
5 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ธันวาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
4 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ธันวาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ 2  2
65 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ 20  22 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่ง
นี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันอังคารอผู้หญิง
ทำไมมาวันพุธคะครูฟ้าิง
นะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 6 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
ธันวาคมปีพพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครู
ฟ้าตอนนี้
เวลา 1800
น 1800 น 18:00 น 6 นค่ะ 18:00 นกี่นาที
คะ 6 นาทีอุ๊ย 66 แล้วก็วันเอาดีนะวันนี้
ไม่ใช่วันที่ 6 นะคะ 66 นครูฟัวันนี้เรา 2
คนตื่นเร็วมากเลยวันนี้เรา 2 คนตื่นเร็ว
6:00 นเราตื่นแล้วปกติครูหญิงเนี่ยทุกๆ
วันนะคะครูฟ้าก็จะตื่น
ประมาณ
น
โอยเอ่อ 848 นเลยเหรอคะหิงเรียนครูฟ้าค่ะ
ต้องตื่น 8:00
นใช่ๆแล้วครูฟ้าปกติตื่นใช่ค่ะ 48
นาทีครูฟ้าปกติ
ตื่นต
4  43
โอทำไมครูฟ้าไม่ตื่นต
444 ไปเลยหรอคะไม่เอาค่ะเลขมันดีเกินไป
นะคะฟก็เลยตื่น
43 อคูณฟ้าตื่นมาทำอะไรเร็วขนาดนี้คะครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยตื่นมากินข้าวค่ะครู
ิงกินข้าวตั้งแต่ 4:00 นเนี่ยนะเอ้ากิน
ข้าวเพราะว่าประเทศไทยเนี่ยอาหารไทย is
the  best นะคะนักเรียนอร่อยมากครูฟ้าก็
เลยชอบที่จะตื่นมากินข้าวตอน 4:00 นนัก
เรียนบอกว่ารู้แล้วครูฟ้าครูหญิงพูดทุก
คลิปอาหารไทยอร่อยอาหารไทยอร่อยครูฟ้าจะ
ตื่นมาตั้งแต่ 4:00 นกินข้าวคุณกินข้าว
กี่
ชั่วโมงครูฟ้ากินข้าวประมาณ
3 ทำอะไรคะกินข้าวนานขนาดนั้นน่ะก็กิน
ข้าวไปด้วยดู netflix ไปด้วยไงคะอ๋อครู
ฟ้าชอบดูหนังดูซีรี์ใน netflix เหรอคะใช่
ค่ะครูหญิงครูฟ้าชอบดูหนังดูซีรี่ส์ดู
Everything จิงกาเบลใน netflix นะคะครู
ฟ้ามันสนุกหรออ้าทำไมอ่ะเอ้าก็อย่างเมื่อ
วันไหนนะวันอาอาทิตย์หรือเปล่าวันอาทิตย์
อ่ะเมื่อวานเนี้ยเออเมื่อวานนี้ใช่มั้ย
วันอาทิตย์อ่ะอืวันที่ 4 ธันวาคมค่ะครู
หญิงก็ดูดูหนัง 1 เรื่องใน netflix ใน
netflix เหมือนกันอืผู้หญิงดูหนังอะไรคะ
หนังชื่อ The  woman  in  the  Window
โอ้โหผู้หญิงที่อยู่ในหน้าต่างผู้หญิงที่
อยู่ที่หน้าต่างเนี่ยนะคะเอออืมใชู่้หญิง
ู้หญิงชอบ
หรอไม่ค่ะอ้าดูแล้วก็โอเคแล้วครูหญิงก็
เลยเช็คดูว่าเอ้าหนังเรื่องนี้
เนี่ยมีหนังสือด้วย
อืหนังสือชื่อเหมือนกันเลยว่าผู้หญิงที่
หน้าต่างมี
หนังสือเป็นหนังสือแล้วก็เอาไปทำเป็นหนัง
อืม
ก็เลยคิดว่า
อ้า
หนังสือหลายๆเรื่องเนี่ยเวลาเอาเปลี่ยน
เอาไปทำเป็นหนังเนี่ยมันไม่ค่อยสนุกอ่ะ
ค่ะเวลาเราอ่านหนังสือใช่มั้ยแบบหูสนุก
มากอืแต่พอเอาไปทำเป็นหนังแล้วแบบ
อืสนุกน้อยกว่าเนาะอย่างเช่น Harry  poter
har  po แี่หญิมี Harry  Potter ด้วยนะ
คะนักเรียน 1 เล่มอยู่ที่บ้านหญิงมี Harry
Potter ด้วยเหรอคะใชอันนี้เป็น Harry
Potter เล่ม 5 นะคะ the  Order  of
phenix นะคะนักเรียนนี่อื Harry  Potter
แต่ว่าเป็นภาษาไทยนะภาษาไทย
อือย่าง Harry  Potter ใช่มั้ยคะก็เป็น
หนังสือมเป็นหนังสือก่อนแล้วก็เอาไปทำ
เป็นหนังออืคนที่อ่านหนังสือแล้วไปดูหนัง
เนี่ยก็จะบอก
อืหนังไม่โอเคหนังสือดีกว่าอืแต่คนที่ไม่
เคยอ่านหนังสือแล้วดูหนังก็จะรู้สึกแบบหู
ว้าวสนุกมากใช่มครูหญิงงั้นครูหญิงเนี่ย
ชอบหนังหรือว่าหนังสือมากกว่ากันหรอคะครู
ครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะพูดพูดมานักเรียนเนี่ยคง
จะคิดว่าอู้ครูหญิงต้องชอบหนังสือมากกว่า
หนังใช่มยใช่เพราะครูหญิงพูดพูดพูดว่า
หนังสือดีหนังสือดีหนังสือดีนะฮะหนังไม่
ดีหนังสืออุยผู้หญิงอารมณ์ขนาดนั้นเลยหรอ
อา
เหรอนี่ชอบอ่านหนังสือมากกว่า
หนังสือหรือหนังครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะพูดูดพูด
มาแล้วนักเรียนต้องคิดว่าโอ้ครูหญิงเนี่ย
ต้องชอบหนังสือมากกว่าหนังใช่ไหมยผิด
ค่ะอะไรอ่ะซุปอะไรอ่ะคะ
Superman
ชาซมเลยใช่
Superman อ่ะโอเคจะได้เ์มขอบคุณค่ะติด
ค่ะครูหญิงเนี่ยชอบ
หนังมากกว่าหนังสือครูหญิงเลือกหนังค่ะ
ทีมหนังทำไมครูหญิงถึงเป็นทีมหนังล่ะก่อน
ที่นักเรียนจะคิดว่าทำไมครูฟ้าล่ะครูฟ้า
เป็นทีมหนังสือหรือว่าทีมหนังครูหญิงอนี่
ครูหญิง
ครูฟ้านะคะชอบดู
หนังและไม่ค่อยชอบอ่านหนังสือเท่าไหร่ใช่
มั้ยตอน
นี้ชอบดูหนังมากกว่าดูซีรียส์มากกว่านะคะ
นักเรียนที่นักเรียนเห็นนแต่ครู
ฟ้าชอบอ่านหนังสือมากกว่าดูหนัง
ค่ะถ้าเกิดครูฟ้าดู harry  poter ใช่ไหมย
ครูฟ้าดูแี่พตดูหนังนะคะูฟ้าก็จะคิดเอแี่
poter มีหนังสือมยถ้าแรี่พตมีหนังสือครู
ฟ้าก็จะไปซื้อหนังสือแล้วก็อ่านหนังสือนะ
คะอือือันนี้ Harry  Potter นะ
คะ
ออนี่เอิ่มเขขี่ไม้กวาดคี meg ออครูฟ้า
เนี่ยคิดว่าหนังหนังสือดีกว่าหนังใช่มย
ใช่ว่าชอบอ่านหนังสือมากกว่าหนังอืแต่ครู
หญิงเนี่ยถึงแม้จะรู้สึกว่าหนังสือสนุก
กว่าหนังนะคะแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยชอบดูหนังมาก
กว่าหนังสือครูหญิงทีมหนังค่ะทำไมร
ทำมทำไมใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะ
ทำไมขี้เกียจ
อ่านดูหนังสือสินักเรียนดูหนังสือเนี่ย
หนาขนาดนี้ครูหญิงอ่านเนี่ยอ่านก็อย่าง
น้อย 1 วันอ่ะถ้าครูหญิงชอบมากๆหนังสือ
เล่มนี้นะคะนักเรียนมีทั้ง
หมดกี่หน้า 1
1,000
47 หน้าเนี่ยหนังสือเล่มเนี้ย 1,4  7
หน้าทำไมเยอะเออะจังผู้หญิงชอบมากอยาก
อ่านก็คิดว่าต้องใช้เวลา 24 ชมในการอ่าน
แต่ถ้าู้หญิงดูหนังก็ 2 ช่วโมง
แล้ว
ก็ไม่ต้องทำอะไรนั่งแล้วก็
ดูรู้สึกว่าหนังดีกว่าค่ะก็เลยเลือกหนัง
แล้วครูฟ้าล่ะทำไมครูฟ้าคิดว่าหนังสือดี
กว่าหนังเพราะว่าเวลาที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยอ่าน
หนังสือนะคะครูฟ้าก็จะขอโทษ
ค่ะสมมุติครูฟ้าอ่าน Harry  Potter ถ้าดู
หนังเนี่ยนะฮะอื Harry  Potter เนี่ยก็
คือ Daniel  Red  crp นะคะใช่ไหมมเป็นใช
แฮร์รี่คนที่เล่นคนที่เล่นเป็นแ
อืม Daniel  Red  crp นะคะ Harry  Potter
แต่ถ้าครูฟ้าอ่านหนังสือเนี่ย
อืเป็นยังไงคะ Harry  Potter ก็อันไหนอัน
ไหนครูฟ้าคะนี่ครูฟ้านะคะค่ะนี่ไม่ใช่
แรี่ poter นะคะฟ้านะคะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ค่ะ
ครูฟ้ากำลังอ่าน Harry  Potter อ่าน
หนังสือ
แี่
poter ในความคิดครูฟ้าอาจจะเป็นใครก็ได้
ใช่ไหม
ออ๋อครูฟ้าหมายถึงว่าเวลาที่เราดูหนัง
เนี่ยคนที่เขาทำหนังเนี่ยเขาคิดแล้วว่า
โอเคคนนี้แรี่พตแต่เวลาครูฟ้าอ่านหนังสือ
เองเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็คิดเองใช่มั้ยคะแบบอ้อ
แี่ poter อืหน้าตาเป็นยังไงผมเป็นยังไง
เมนี่หน้าตาเป็นยังไงอใช่มครูฟ้าก็เลยคิด
ว่ามันดีกว่าใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าก็เลยชอบหนังสือ
มากกว่าเราก็จะได้รู้ว่าบ้านของแรี่
poter เป็นยังไงครูฟ้าก็จะคิดเองใช่ไหม
คะไอเดียของครูฟ้าเองคิดเองว่าบ้านของแี่
poter เป็นยังไงแี่ Potter เป็นยังไง
เวลาอ่านหนังสือมีดีเทลเยอะกว่านะคะนัก
เรียนหนังสืออืก็ดูสิคะหนามากหนาขนาด
นี้แต่ถ้าเอาหนังสือไปทำหนังทั้งหมดมันก็
ไม่สนุกไงอืมันก็ต้องเวลาครูฟ้าอ่าน
หนังสือแล้วใช่มยหรือว่านักเรียนที่ชอบ
อ่านหนังสือแล้วเวลานักเรียนรอว่าหนังสือ
อ้านี่ผู้หญิงทีมอะไรคะเนี่ยว่าหนังสือ
ที่เราชอบเนี่ยจะไปทำเป็นหนังหนังเนี่ย
เค้าก็จะตัดตัดตัดอะไรนิดๆหน่อยๆออกใช่ม
แล้วอาจจะเปลี่ยนบ้างคนที่อ่านหนังสือก็
จะไม่ชอบหนังอืแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยเป็นคนที่
ดูหนังก็จะรู้สึกว่าอุ๊หนังสือเนี่ยเยอะ
อันเนี้ยไม่โอเคไม่เอาไม่เอามีทำไมดีเทล
เล็กๆๆที่ครูฟ้า
บอกหนังสือดีค่ะออืไม่ใช่ค่ะหนังดีกว่า
เพราะว่าเวลาที่มันเป็นหนังใช่
มยมีคนคิดมีคนทำเสร็จแล้วเราก็นั่งดูอัน
นี้อะไรคะหนังสือดีค่ะหนังสือดีหนังสิคะ
หนังมีคนอย่างครูฟ้าบอกว่าแี่ poter ก็มี
Daniel  Red คิปเนี่ยเล่นแล้วเราก็ดูอ
แล้วถ้าหนังสือเนี่ยนะคะครูฟ้าอืหนาขนาด
เนี้ยถ้าครูหญิงชอบมากๆครูหญิงอยากจะอ่าน
อีก 1 ครั้งอ่ะอ่านครั้งที่ 2 ก็ได้แค่
เห็น
หนังสือเหนื่อยแล้วค่ะแต่ถ้าเป็นหนัง
เนี่ยอ้าวอุ้ยอ้าอุ๊ยอะไรคะครูหญิงหายไป
แล้วนะคะนัก
เรียนครูหญิงหายไปแล้วนะคะโอเคแป๊บนึงนะ
คะ
มันลบไปทสินะคะนักเรียนหน้านักของครูหญิง
อ่ะแต่้าครูหญิงเนี่ยกลับมาดูหน้าของเรา
ปกติแล้วกันนะคะแต่ถ้าครูหญิงดู
หนังหนังเนี่ยก็ใช้เวลา 2 ชั่วมงประมาณ 2
ช่วโมงครูหญิงชอบก็ดูแล้วดูอีกดูแล้วดู
อีกดูแล้วดูหลายๆครั้งได้แต่หนังสือโอ้
ชอบแต่ว่าอ่าน 1 ครั้งก็พอแล้วครูฟ้าเอ้า
ครูหญิงครูฟ้ายังอ่านเพี่ Jackson หลายๆ
ครั้งเลยอุยแต่มันใช้เวลานานไงครูฟ้าผู้
หญิงก็อ่านเร็วๆสิคะเพิ่มสปีดในการ
อ่านเหมถ้าครูหญิงดูหนังครูหญิงเพิ่มสปีด
เวลาดูได้เร็วๆได้ครูฟ้าก็เพิ่มปีในการ
อ่านได้ค่ะครูหญิงเพเป็นคนอ่านหนังสือ
เร็วมากๆครูหญิงทำไม่ได้ไงครูหญิงก็เลย
คิดว่าหนังดีกว่าหนังสือนะครูฟ้าคิดว่า
หนังสือดีกว่าหนังค่ะเอ้าแล้วมันดีกว่า
ยังไงอีกครูฟ้านอกจากครูฟ้าจะคิดเองได้
แล้วอ่ะคิดเองได้แล้ว
หนังสือมันทำให้เราเนี่ยไปอ่านที่ไหนก็
ได้นะครูหญิงเราจะไปร้านกาแฟแล้วก็อ่าน
หนังสือได้ค่ะเพราะว่าเราไม่ต้องใส่หูฟัง
เราไม่ต้องฟังอะไรดังๆใช่ไหมมนักเรียนเรา
ก็อ่านหนังสือได้ทุกที่เลยนะคะแล้วก็
หนังสือเนี่ยมันทำให้เรามี
vocabulary
โอ๊ยใช่ไหมอ๋อมันทำให้เราเนี่ยได้อ่าน
แล้วก็ได้รู้จักคำใหม่ๆใช่ค่ะรู้จักภาษา
ไทยใหม่ๆหรือว่าภาษาอังกฤษใหม่ๆถ้าอ่าน
เวอร์ชั่นภาษาอังกฤษใช่มั้ยคะแต่ถ้าเราดู
หนังเนี่ยมันก็เหมือนกับนักเรียนเรียน
ภาษาไทยตอนนี้ใช่มเราก็ได้เห็นภาพมีคนแช
แสดงแล้วเราก็ได้ฟังภาษาอังกฤษด้วยโอ๊ยดี
กว่าแค่ดูแล้วก็ฟังเข้าใจเลยถ้าครูหญิง
ต้องอ่านแรี่พตเป็นภาษาอังกฤษเนี่ยครู
หญิงก็อ่านแล้วก็ไม่เข้าใจไม่เข้าใจครู
หญิงก็ต้องเปิด Dictionary  Google
Translation ก็ไม่โอเคโาโเคะถ้าเปิด
Google  Translation แล้วไม่โอเคเขาจะมี
Google  Translation ไว้ทำไมคหิอ้ามัน
เป็นสเต็ปต่อไปแล้วค่ะคพะดูหนังไปแล้วแต่
มันไม่ใช่ Natural  Way อย่าไงค่ะคะมัน
ไม่ใช่มันไม่ใช่วิธีที่เราสอนมันไม่ใช่
comprehensible  input มันไม่ใช่ไงมัน
เป็นการเปิด Dictionary แล้วเราก็จำพอจำ
แล้วเราก็ลืมแต่ถ้าเราดูหนังเนี่ยเราเห็น
เป็นภาพเราฟังเราเข้าใจไม่ลืมมันเป็นสต็ป
ต่อไปของการหลังจากที่นักเรียนดูแล้วฟัง
มาแล้วค่ะนักเรียนหนังสือมีไว้ทำไมคะมี
ไว้อ่านนะคะนักเรียนการอ่านหนังสือดีที่
สุดทุกคนรู้โลกรู้ว่าเราต้องอ่านหนังสือ
นะคะนักเรียนยังไงก็ตามเราต้องอ่าน
หนังสือนะคะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยไม่ค่ะการ
อ่านหนังสือดีที่สุดเราจะได้รู้อะไรใหม่ๆ
นะนักเรียนนอกจากการฟังไม่ค่ะคำศัพท์ไม่
เก่าไปแล้วคำศัพท์ในหนังสือเนี่ยภาษาไทย
ภาษาอังกฤษในหนังสือมันเป็นอีกสเต็ปอีก
เลเวลนึงนะคะนักเรียนเราจะได้รู้ไงเอ้าก็
ถ้าหนังสือเป็นภาษาไทยแบบนี้ใช่มั้ย
หนังสือเป็นภาษาไทยอใชครูหญิงก็เห็นด้วย
กับครูฟ้านะคิดเหมือนครูฟ้าว่าโอเคถ้า
อ่านหนังสือเป็นภาษาไทยอืก็อ่านหนังสือ
เราจะได้รู้จักอะไรใหม่ๆคำศัพท์ใหม่ๆ
แต่ถ้าดู
หนังนักเรียนยังไม่ยังอ่านภาษาไทยไม่ได้
มันถก็อ่านภาษาอังกฤษสิครูโอ๊ยครูหญิง
เนี่ยจริงๆครูหญิงก็อ่านภาษาอังกฤษได้นะ
คะแต่ว่ายังไม่ได้เป็นเลเวลที่แบบอ่าน
หนังสือแล้วเข้าใจไงอืก็ดูหนังก่อนแล้วก็
เข้าใจแล้วก็ไปอ่านหนังสือไม่ได้หรอดู
หนังก่อนแล้วเข้าใจแล้วก็ไปอ่านหนังสือ
ไม่ได้หรอแล้วแต่แต่นักเรียนนะฮะว่านัก
เรียนอยากจะดูหนังหรืออ่านหนังสือนะคะนัก
เรียนเพราะว่ามันก็มีให้เราเลือเลือกนะฮะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยดูหนังบ้างแล้วก็ไปอ่าน
หนังสือบ้างนะคะแต่ครูฟ้าชอบอ่านหนังสือ
มากกว่าครูฟ้าก็คือถ้าครูฟ้ารู้ว่าหนัง
เรื่องนี้ทำมาจากหนังสือเหมือนแี่ poter
Percy  Jackson  The  Lord  Of  The
dring อย่างเงี้ยทำมาจากหนังสือครูฟ้าก็
จะไปเลือกซื้อหนังสือไม่ได้เลือกดูหนัง
ต่ออ๋อแต่ถ้าครูหญิงรู้ว่าหนังเรื่องนี้
ทำมาจากหนังสืออือครูหญิงก็จะดูหนังก่อน
นะคะถ้าครูหญิงชอบหนังเรื่องนี้มากๆอืครู
หญิงก็จะไม่อ่าน
หนังสืออย่าไม่สนุกมถ้าก็ดูหนังแล้วใช่
มั้ยถ้าเราชอบแล้วไปอ่านหนังสือเนี่ย
หนังสือมันก็ดีกว่าอยู่ดีไงครูฟ้าถึงแม้
ครูหญิงจะทีทีมหนังก็เหอะนักเรียนแต่ยัง
ไงเนี่ยหนังสือมันก็สนุกมากกว่าครูหิงก็
เลยคิดว่าถ้าเรื่องไหนชอบมากๆไม่อ่านดู
หนังไม่อ่านหนังสือแต่ถ้าเรื่องไหนอย่าง
วันอาทิตย์ใช่มยที่ครูหญิงดูหนัง The
woman  in  the  Window เนี่ยหนังมัน
โอเคูหญิงก็เลยคิดหนังสือน่าจะสนุกนะ
อืแล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะนักเรียนเนี่ยทีมอะไร
ทีมหนังสือเหมือนครูฟ้าหรือว่าทีมหนัง
เหมือนครูหญิงคอมเมนต์บอกเราได้นะคะผู้
หญิงคิดว่าผู้หญิงต้องไม่มีทีมแน่ๆเลยอ่ะ
นักเรียอาจจะชอบดูหนังกันเยอะนะคะู้หญิง
ก็ได้หมายถึงว่ามันต้องเป็นหนังที่ทำจาก
หนังสือไงอือใช่มั้ยคะโอเคค่ะนักเรียนก็
คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้นะว่านักเรียนทีม
หนังสือหรือว่าทีมหนังส่วนวีดีโอนี้ครู
หญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามา
เจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ